what I like about Dancing with the Stars
anyone can dance doesn't matter anyone
can dance and what I hope is that people
watch the show and they think I'd like
to have a go at that and it gets people
exercising and dancing and learning
about the joys of having a dance Len
Goodman has died he was 78 years old
[Music]
lens manager confirmed the sad news to
the BBC Monday morning explaining that
the former Dancing with the Stars judge
passed away peacefully a much-loved
husband father and grandfather who will
be sorely missed by family friends and
all who knew him according to the report
Len had bone cancer and was in Hospice
at his home in Kent England when he died
on Saturday surrounded by his family
Len appeared as a judge on Dancing With
the Stars from 2005 until 2022. I
thought a metamorphosis last week a
caterpillar this week
I think it's a great show and I'm just
happy to be a little part of it it's
been fantastic he also served as a
founding judge on the British Dance
Competition Strictly Come Dancing from
2004 to 2016.
[Music]
Lane announced his retirement from the
hit ABC Series in November saying he
wanted to spend more time with his
grandchildren and family in Britain I'm
gonna miss the judges
Carrie Anne and Bruno we've been
together since season one
and then Derek I think he's brilliant I
loved it I loved being a part of it and
I loved working with you you were great
it's been such a joy for me to be a part
of Dancing With the Stars it really has
I've had such a wonderful time and this
is absolutely the cherry on the coast
Len was a former dancer himself winning
the British championship in his 20s
before ending his dancing career to
become a professional judge following
news of Len's death fellow judge Bruno
Tonioli posted this sweet snap to
Instagram writing that his heart is
broken I will treasure the memory of our
incredible adventures and hundreds of
shows we did together it's funny it's
very very funny I mean I know him we
started the show together in the UK so
he's like my brother Len is survived by
his wife Sue Goodman son James Goodman
and two grandchildren Alice and Dan
foreign